THEY SAT AT THE AIRPORT THE LAST
COUPLE OF DAYS.
WE KNOW THE REASON WHY, THE
TALIBAN WANT SOMETHING IN
EXCHANGE.
>> AMERICAN HELD HOSTAGE, DAY
24.
>> DAY 24 THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION STILL DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY AMERICANS
OFFICIALLY LEFT BEHIND AND
THERE IS ZERO PLAN TO GET THEM
OUT.
THE HOSTAGES ABANDONED BY
JOE BIDEN.
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN ABANDONED BY
FELLOW AMERICANS.
SIX CHARTER PLANES FROM GREAT
AMERICANS AROUND THE COUNTRY,
INCLUDING RETIRED SPECIAL OPS,
OFFICERS ON THE GROUND RISKING
THEIR LIVES AND OTHER PRIVATE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE NOW ON THE
TARMAC IN AN AIRPORT IN NORTHERN
AFGHANISTAN.
THEY ARE READY TO TAKE OFF,
CARING AMERICANS AND/OR ALLIES
TO QATAR.
ACCORDING TO VARIOUS REPORTS,
THE PLANES ARE BLOCKED BY THE
TALIBAN AND OTHERS AND I HAVE
BEEN BLOCKED, IN SOME CASES, FOR
SIX, LONG DAYS.
EVEN THE U.S. STATE DEPARTMENT
IS NOT HELPING.
THE TALIBAN IS APPARENTLY
DEMANDING A RANSOM PAYMENT FROM
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT, THE
STATE DEPARTMENT REPORTEDLY
REFUSING TO GRANT APPROVAL FOR
PRIVATE EVACUATION FLIGHTS TO
LAND IN OTHER COUNTRIES.
THAT IS INSANE.
NOT ONLY IS THE BIDEN STATE
DEPARTMENT DOING NOTHING TO
RESCUE OUR FELLOW AMERICANS THAT
THEY ABANDONED, AND NOW THEY ARE
REPORTEDLY OBSTRUCTING PRIVATE
RESCUE MISSIONS BY A LOT OF
RETIRED OPS GUYS, SPECIAL
FORCES, WILLING TO PUT THEIR OWN
LIVES AT RISK TO HELP THE
AMERICANS THAT HE ABANDONED.
THE AMERICANS SUPPOSED TO BOARD
THESE PLANES AND SHOWED UP AT
THE AIRPORT.
THEY FORKED OVER THEIR PAPERS TO
THE TALIBAN, AND ONCE AGAIN,
TONIGHT THEY ARE IN HIDING AND
MORE VULNERABLE THAN EVER.
ONE UNNAMED PERSON INVOLVED WITH
THIS EXTRACTION EFFORTS TELLING
FOX NEWS "IF ONE LIFE IS LOST AS
A RESULT OF THIS, THE BLOOD IS
ON THE WHITE HOUSE'S HANDS.
THEIR BLOOD IS ON THEIR HANDS."
IT IS NOT THE TALIBAN THAT IS
HOLDING US UP AS MUCH AS IT
SICKENS ME TO SAY, IT IS THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT.
THIS IS SO BAD, EVEN DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR, HUGE LIBERAL
RICHARD BLUMENTHAL, CONNECTICUT,
IS BLASTING THE ADMINISTRATION
OVER THEIR INCOMPETENCE.
ARE YOU OKAY WITH THIS?
RON KLAIN, TONY BLINKEN,
JOE BIDEN, IF YOU ARE AWAKE,
SUSAN RICE?
IS THIS ONE OF THE CONTINGENCIES
THAT YOU PLAN FOR ALSO, OR DO
YOU JUST NOT CARE THAT YOU
ABANDONED AMERICANS AND LEFT
THEM PRETTY MUCH FOR DAD TO FEND
FOR THEMSELVES A QUESTION THAT'S
RIGHT, UNDER TERRORIST RULE.
THANKFULLY TONIGHT, WE HAVE GOOD
NEWS TO REPORT OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN.
THERE WAS AN AMERICAN MOTHER
FROM TEXAS.
HER THREE CHILDREN WERE RESCUED
BY AN A A MAN NAMED CORY MILLS
WHO WILL JOIN US ON THE PROGRAM
IN A MINUTE.
THE PRIVATE TEAM OF MILITARY
VETS IN A SUCCESSFUL
CROSS-BORDER OPERATIONS AND
DESPITE HAVING NO INVOLVEMENT IN
THE RESCUE MISSION, GUESS WHAT,
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION INTEND
TO TAKE IT UP FOR SOMETHING THEY
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH.
ACCORDING TO THE
STATE DEPARTMENT, THE
UNITED STATES HAS FACILITATED
THIS SAFE DEPARTURE OF FOUR
CITIZENS BY AFGHANISTAN.
THE ORGANIZER OF THIS RESCUE
MISSION IS CALLING THAT
STATEMENT A COMPLETE AND TOTAL
LIFE HERE THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
DID NOTHING TO RESCUE THESE
AMERICANS, ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING AND OF COURSE JOE BIDEN
DOESN'T SEEM TO CARE ABOUT ANY F
THIS BECAUSE TODAY AFTER A
LONG WEEKEND OF GETTING MUCH
NEEDED REST AND RELAXATION IN
DELAWARE, BIDEN TOURED FLOOD
DAMAGE IN NEW YORK AND
NEW JERSEY AND EVERY STOP MET BY
PROTESTERS CARING ANTI-BIDEN
SIGNS WAVING TRUMP FLAGS IN
DEMANDING ACCOUNTABILITY OVER
AFGHANISTAN AND MORE.
ACCORDING TO JOE BIDEN,
EVERYBODY HE THOUGHT WAS HAPPY
TO SEE HIM.
IT THE FEW PEOPLE THAT WERE
THERE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> NONE OF THEM WERE SHOUTING OR
COMPLAINING.
EVERY ONE OF THEM WERE THANKING
ME AS IF IT WAS SOMETHING
SPECIAL.
I MEAN THAT SINCERELY, THAT I
WAS HERE.
>> [BLEEP]!
YOU HAVE RENT AMERICANS LIVES.
[BLEEP] MACK!
YOU HAVE LEFT AMERICANS BEHIND
[BLEEP] YOU GUYS.
YOU GUYS.
YOU LEFT AMERICANS BEHIND!
>> 2011!
HE LOST HIS LIFE FOR WHAT!
>> Sean: FINALLY BIDEN HAD TO
MENTION THE PROTESTERS, BUT HE
ACCUSED THEM OF BEING IGNORANT.
BIDEN MADE NO MENTION AT ALL OF
AFGHANISTAN.
NOTHING ABOUT THE SEA ABANDONED
OR THOSE BEING HELD HOSTAGE
BEHIND ENEMY LINES IN NORTHERN
AFGHANISTAN.
NOTHING AT ALL.
NOTHING ABOUT THE BILLIONS OF
EQUIPMENT YOU LEFT BEHIND.
INSTEAD, HE FOCUSED ON A MUCH
MORE PRESSING AND URGENT
SITUATION.
CLIMATE CHANGE.
ONLY PROBLEM FOR JOE IS HE'S
EITHER TOO STUPID OR FRANKLY,
TOO IMPAIRED TO SPEAK
COHERENTLY.
WE HAVE THE VIDEOTAPE EVIDENCE
AND OF COURSE, WE WILL LET YOU
DECIDE TO.
>> THE GROUP I HAVE STANDING
WITH ME LED BY CHUCK SCHUMER AND
YOUR CONGRESSWOMAN, IS THIS YOUR
DISTRICT?
AND ZERO EMISSIONS, NET
EMISSIONS BY 2050.
BY 2020, MAKE SURE ALL
ELECTRICITY IS ZERO EMISSIONS.
THIS SUMMER ALONE, COMMUNITIES
WITH OVER 100 MILLION AMERICANS,
100 AMERICANS CALL HOME HAVE
BEEN STRUCK BY EXTREME WEATHER.
>> EACH DOLLAR WE INVEST, EVERY
DOLLAR WE RAISE, A CITY BLOCK BY
2 FEET FLOOD PROOF POWER
STATIONS.
SANITATION'S.
>> Sean: REMEMBER EVERY SINGLE
DAY DONALD TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT,
THE LEFT, THE MEDIA MOB
PRETENDED TO BE, YOU KNOW,
PAINTING WAS SO MUCH OUTRAGE AND
EMBARRASSED BY DONALD TRUMP TO
EAT.
I WILL TAKE A MEAN TWEET IN A
DAY OVER A BANDING AMERICANS.
NOW, HOW HUMILIATING, THINKING
AS AMERICANS AS THIS UNFOLDS,
HOW HUMILIATING AND HOW
EMBARRASSING IS ALL OF THIS?
YOU HAVE A REPULSIVE DISGUSTING
AND PREVENTABLE DISGRACE AND
UNMITIGATED DISASTER ALL
PREVENTABLE.
YOU WATCH THE TALIBAN ON THE
MONTH OF MARCH AND APRIL AND IN
MAY AND IN JUNE AND IN JULY WHEN
WE COULD HAVE SAFELY EVACUATED
OUR OWN FELLOW AMERICANS, ALL OF
OUR ALLIES AND ALL OF OUR
MILITARY EQUIPMENT THAT THEY NOW
HAVE IN THEIR POSSESSION.
IT IS A DISGRACE!
THE ALLIES AROUND THE WORLD ARE
SHOCKED.
THEY ARE HORRIFIED, AND
AMERICANS IN THE KNEES OR
COMPLETELY ENFOLDED.
IT IS NOT JUST THE STAMINA AND
CONFUSION FROM A MAN AND SEVERE
COGNITIVE DECLINE BUT ALSO, THIS
IS IMPORTANT.
WE DON'T LEAVE OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS BEHIND.
I CAN TELL YOU THIS, HANNITY
KNOWS DONALD TRUMP, I DO.
DONALD TRUMP WOULD HAVE
OBLITERATED THE TALIBAN IF THEY
MADE ONE WRONG MOVE.
JUST LIKE HE DID BAGHDADI AND
ASSOCIATES AND AL QAEDA LEADER
IN YEMEN AND SOLD THE MONEY AND
DESTROYED THE ENTIRE CALIPHATE
AND IRAQ AND SYRIA.
JOE BIDEN DID NOTHING ON THE
MARCH AND WE KNOW IT FOR MONTHS.
OUR INTEL COMMUNITY DIDN'T FAIL.
THEY WARNED THEM EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
THESE DOCUMENTS WILL BE
REVEALED.
WE DON'T ABANDON AMERICANS AND
HOSTILE, FOREIGN COUNTRIES RUN
BY A RADICAL, ISLAMIC
EXTREMISTS.
WE DON'T PUT THE LIVES OF FELLOW
AMERICANS IN THEIR HANDS.
THAT IS NOT WHO WE ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE OR WHO WE ARE!
THIS IS NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT DEMOCRAT,
REPUBLICAN, CONSERVATIVE OR
LIBERAL.
IF EVERYONE STUCK BEHIND ENEMY
LINES, AND WANT THEM HOME TRYING
TO GET ME FIRED.
THIS IS ABOUT SAVING OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS LIVES.
ONE EXAMPLE: A PREGNANT WOMAN
NOW IN HIDING, WHY?
SHE GOT KICKED IN THE STOMACH BY
A TALIBAN FIGHTER WHILE
ATTEMPTING TO REACH THE AIRPORT
MULTIPLE TIMES.
SHE SAYS THAT AMERICANS ARE
BEING HUNTED ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
WE HAVE MORE HAVE MORE ANTIDOTAL
STORIES DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
ACCORDING TO CONGRESSMAN DARRELL
EISMAN, AT LEAST 500 AMERICANS
WHO ARE STILL TRAPPED, INCLUDING
MULTIPLE STUDENTS FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND IF YOU ADD IN
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS, GUESS
WHAT?
IT IS OVER A THOUSAND THAT NEED
TO BE HOME RIGHT HERE ON
AMERICAN SOIL.
TO MAKE MATTERS WORSE, GET THIS,
MORE GITMO DETAINEES RELEASED BY
BIDEN AND OBAMA IN EXCHANGE FOR
BOWE BERGDAHL AND NOW SENIOR
TALIBAN POSITIONS.
THIS IS A NIGHTMARE, A HOSTAGE
CRISIS ON A MASSIVE SCALE THAT
WILL LIKELY CONTINUE.
I DON'T EVEN WANT TO DISCUSS MY
WORST FEARS HERE.
BUT THINK ABOUT DANIEL PEARL.
YOU KNOW WHERE I'M HEADED.
I PRAYED TO GOD THAT I AM WRONG.
I PRAY THAT EVERY ONE OF THESE
AMERICANS NOW TRAPPED BEHIND
ENEMY